we got uh really crazy news two
absolutely shocking stories the first I
did not believe it when good sir Brandon
read it I said there's no way that's
true the governor of New Mexico has just
decreed the possession of guns to be
illegal
that that's that's the headline I'm not
exaggerating I didn't believe it when I
heard it granted there's some Nuance to
it but outright the governor has
declared a public health emergency in
which it is now illegal to possess a
firearm in public even though the state
is an open carry state this is
I'll keep it light for the intro but for
those that know their history when
Executives declare the seizure of
weapons typically historically in many
places really bad things follow that
I am uh extremely worried to hear this
news breaking today and um 10 minutes
ago uh maybe about 20 minutes ago